hey this is Steve montro with collider
and uh I'm here at our media Studio at
the cinema center at marble and uh
David's gonna kill me for one of these
things but thanks David how you guys
doing really we're doing great thank you
first of all thank you so much for
coming in and congrats on your movie
um I hate doing this right at the
beginning but like no one will have seen
this who's watching this interview yet
and I want to make sure people seek it
out so how have you been describing
Wildcat to like friends and family or
whoever well briefly put it's
um the story of Flannery O'Connor uh one
of the most brilliant American Writers
uh she was writing in the 50s and she
died in the early 60s and the movie
follows a few months of her life when
she was about 24 years old and was given
a death sentence she found it finds out
that she has lupus which is the same
disease that killed her father when she
was young and so it's a really pivotal
moment in her life where she has to kind
of accept the reality of her situation
so that's the plot of the movie in truth
the movie's a lot weirder than that yeah
in truth it's about um um the
intersection of like the faith and
Imagination and uh kind of exploring a
young woman's trajectory into
understanding and contextualizing her
upbringing as a Catholic into her
growing up as a writer and um and how to
kind of sow seeds of consistency and
Faith between those two things one of
the things I found interesting when I
was reading uh you know about the the
making of this is that you actually have
a history with her writing going back to
like when you were a teenager just just
the only history that kind of most
people have going back to being a
teenager which is that usually an
English Professor assigns it
um and so it's the ordinary history
um and but I guess the only less
ordinary thing is that I had a dad who I
thought would really like her prayer
Journal
um which is kind of a inner monologue uh
her addressing God as she tries to
contextualize how ambitious she is with
how much she wants to be a good Catholic
and that was really interesting to me as
a young person especially because she
had so much so such big dreams and so
much self-doubt for different reasons
than I had but um but I related to it
and connected to it and so we read that
together and then I ended up using it as
an audition monologue when I was uh
applying to drama schools and um and
then kind of just kept wanting to play
this character
um and eventually this this film came
together through a variety of
not that interesting but to talk about
but at the time very surprising and
interesting ways what is interesting is
that you know I comment I you know I've
been acting for 30 years or so and I've
learned that when an actor has a real
passion for a part for a character when
there's something inside them that they
really want to communicate oh it's
really smart to hit your wagons to that
horse you know because that kind of Um
passion can can make something beautiful
you can build around that and Maya's
love of Flannery O'Connor and
how challenging a person she was and she
also brings up so many interesting
questions that are worth exploring so
I never we have lots of ideas of things
we want to do I'm frankly as surprised
as anybody else that this one actually
happened yeah you dream of making lots
of different things and it's kind of up
to the universe to decide which door is
open and which one's close it's funny it
feels like you can like there's have a 5
one seems like an obvious
it was like well that'll never happen
but it's fun to talk about but you never
know what the universe is gonna
like make possible yeah I've spoken to a
lot of filmmakers and one of the reasons
why they attach themselves to five or
eight different things is because they
and huge name directors because they
don't know what's going to be the thing
that goes you really don't know and the
truth is almost any story could be great
if told the right way one of my favorite
Flannery O'Connor lines is that every
writer any human being who lives to
around the age of eight has more than
enough material for a lifetime it's just
whatever is happening you could write a
great novel about the collider set here
if you were observant enough I don't
think I'm smart enough but yes you're
right we probably could do so well yeah
if you mixed in the other sounds like
sketch comedy you could do something
cool if we introduce the element of like
um directors and actors and what it's
like behind the scenes but it could be a
little too inside baseball unless there
is Love Inside yeah like Moby Dick is
inside baseball right you know you can
do great work from inside baseball I
will remember this and when I put it
together the two of you are getting a
phone call if you do not mind um but one
of the things I found so interesting is
the way you told the story and using her
stories and having people play multiple
characters non-linear storytelling
um can you sort of talk about the The
Narrative structure of what you how you
wanted to tell the story yeah you know I
mean I really believe
um
I I believe that it's an old old ancient
idea that thought leads action you know
everything in this room happened first
in our heads you know it has to be
dreamed of before anything exists so in
a lot of ways people always think oh
your dreams your imagination that's not
real but in many ways it is real uh and
I had this experience when Maya had the
idea of making a movie about final
O'Connor I was like all right I had read
a bunch of her when I was younger but I
just spent the summer and I read her
entire works and I started to see her
arise from her own writing and I thought
that that was I just could picture this
woman I thought wow she's communicating
who she is by her themes and what she's
thinking about it's like could you make
a movie that did that and how exciting
that would be as an actor that we all
have different aspects of ourself people
like to say he's this way or she's that
way or this person's it well they are
that way in that context you know and I
thought wouldn't it be an exciting part
to give Maya to play all the different
or many different aspects of Flannery
O'Connor not just one characterization
but to create a three-dimensional
portrait of a young woman by showing all
the different ways that she could be and
I thought wow if that was well executed
that would be worth that would be a
movie worth seeing
um and that's where it all
came from I definitely have to ask you
um you've been directed by very talented
people but what is it like when your dad
is giving you Direction and maybe you're
you're not delivering exactly what he
wants you you know it's funny when we
started this project both of our friends
came up to us and were like oh are you
nervous to work with your daughter you
never stroke with your dad so
persistently that we started to get
nervous
um like we we weren't nervous about that
aspect and I I think a big part of it is
that a collaborative Dynamic is one
we've had my whole life I was gonna say
our whole lives and then I remembered I
wasn't there for the first half of yours
um but um but my whole life and like and
so working together like helping me do
audition tapes um helping me with my
Juilliard audition
um doing play readings together uh
reading out loud writing poems um and
working together and being in a dynamic
of understanding that we were learning
from each other and growing and and
finding the truth between the two
different opinions that we're
communicating is what we've done our our
whole life so my Dad giving me a note
felt better than anybody else ever
giving me a note because I believe that
he thinks I'm worthwhile
um and that's the scary thing when
you're working with someone is do I
trust their note do I think that they
know what's good and do they think I'm
garbage like am I am how bad is this
going to make me feel about myself and
I'd really trust that he knows what's
good um in terms of acting both because
he's really good and you know and has
been teaching me things my whole life
and I also this is such a long answer
that was unnecessary that I'm realizing
it's actually really good um it's
complimentary of me it is yeah yeah but
I also know that he likes me
um and so if he would give me a note it
didn't make me worry that he had
regretted hiring me
um you know there's so many things I
want to say to that one is that one of
the great wonderful things about getting
older and you hear as a young person in
your whole life like that there's this
Mentor student relationship that happens
and obviously if I've had mentors what I
didn't know is how wonderful it when you
are the alleged Mentor how much you're
learning from the younger person
I I didn't know that you're learning a
how to communicate what you've learned
and put it into words and you're also
absorbing their fire their passion their
integrity
um their enthusiasm you know these
really valuable things that get lost
along the way so the two of us felt like
a it was a great Dynamic for us we knew
that to be blessed as a father and
daughter to get to have an at-bat it's a
chance to make meaningful substantive
work together that that would work the
hardest we've ever that was a luxury
there's a Target on your back when you
do that like why do you get to work with
your family you know
um so you have to try at least to do the
best you possibly can and I sensed it
from my uh
Maya was the you know the first there
the last to leave she was working so
hard she was helping me reach out to
actors helping us rehearse help you know
and Laura Linney is a huge part of this
Dynamic too
um that she's not here today but but she
was a
a pivot point that that we both built
around yeah she's kind of good she's
kind of good she's kind of good she is a
future I think yeah
yeah my direction I think she had some
breakthroughs yeah yeah you know what I
mean I really guided her to working with
me yeah yeah
that is 100 True without a doubt um so I
love talking about the editing room
because it's where it all comes together
so how did the film change in the
editing room in ways that perhaps you
weren't expecting and did you ever want
to visit the editing room to see which
takes he was going to use or were you
sort of like I don't want to see it till
there's a cut that he's happy with I've
been sitting with the dream of this
project for so long that being a part of
bringing it into reality in the in that
editing way like when I came and saw an
early cut I was like oh I want to see it
when it's done like I I am so I felt so
vulnerable in that process because I I
put so much of myself into it
um and I love the movie so much now but
I didn't uh I didn't I wanted I wanted
the director to to to shape them movie
and um I someday I hope to get to sit in
an editing room but it wasn't today sure
you know it's funny that you say that
because um
you know you first started talking about
trust in a relationship part of why I
think it felt good for us working
against we trust each other and you know
who was just in your room right here was
Richard link letter and it was kind of
the first experience I had when I was
exactly your age working with him where
I didn't really want to see multiple
cuts to the movie I I understood that I
was I put a lot into Before Sunrise and
I cared a lot about it but I really did
trust him to make the right decisions
and I would he had invited me so much
into the process while we were filming
yeah that I felt like it was important
not to disrespect that invitation that
I've and I felt like you gave that to me
that's exactly I didn't want I was
worried that if I started getting I
would I would see like I'd be like you
have to use take three yeah you're such
an artist you can't do it halfway I
can't do it halfway she's either gonna
be in the editing room breathing down my
neck the whole time or let go and you
decided to let go exactly in in regards
to the actual math of editing I love it
because it's like a Rubik's Cube or
something when it's the right cut it
seems so obvious
but it avoids you for weeks sometimes
why is this scene not working why oh
you're supposed to be on her listening
not on him talking or there's these
weird little things that happened the
music and the rhythm of editing that I
find so interesting I have to um if you
don't mind I'm gonna have to ask another
question but it's not about this film
how do you feel when someone's sitting
across from you wearing a bootleg shirt
of a movie that you did I'm just curious
he wonders where his five cents are yeah
yeah do I get a profit no I think
um
mysterious thoughts even to myself like
you're told your whole life that
what the definitions of success are
status accumulation of wealth power
Awards
um these things that we see as symbols
and if somebody's got a t-shirt on of a
movie you made 27 28 years ago
that means
that means something else that's
unnameable to me that uh and a movie
that was hard to make a movie that no
one told you you have to make not a
giant like an art movie was a flop yeah
you know people people didn't really
like that movie when it first came out
people reviewing it people like you know
there were no t-shirts made the year it
came out sure you know we used to Rick
and I used to joke this is the lowest
grossing film to ever uh Garner a sequel
you know which I think is true
um and uh so it I knew we had friends I
knew it was a good movie I knew there
were friends in the world like
like-minded people like yourself that
would like the movie we just didn't find
them right away uh so it gives me hope
that every project you don't know what
happens in the universe you know you
just don't does that make sense you know
um uh and I'm curious for you though
growing up with a dad who is an actor
and has done so many cool projects can
you watch his films and like take like
and enjoy them and as an audience member
or do you see your dad like what is it
like actually having a family member do
you know what I mean in the middle I
mean I have two
um
soon to be three soon to be three
um yeah but I I
uh it's it's first of all I'm not an
expert in that like I didn't grow up
watching all like it wasn't like oh
every Friday night we catch up on the
filmography like you know uh it was and
I didn't go to Every Premiere I I didn't
really start going and seeing things
until I got really interested in in
doing it myself
um we kept our kind of family space a
family space and and not a museum to
anyone's accomplishments um except like
you know like yogurt label prizes for
you know thanks for thanks for playing
at field day
um but um I it's it's cool I think you
know I mean I saw what I'm in some a lot
of plays when I was younger and if bad
things happened to people that you love
even in stories it's really upsetting
um and I felt that way watching movies
too and I watched uh Kill Bill 2 and I
was like deeply deeply upset
um of an age what's too young I mean I I
think I saw Ghostbusters at 12 and it
felt too scary so I'm sensitive
um but it's weird and it's fine and it's
cool sometimes it's you know and
sometimes it's sad yeah I have actor
friends and sometimes it's I can they
disappear into the role and sometimes
I'm seeing my friend on screen it's
really weird yeah it's yeah it all
depends I actually want to ask you about
in the movie there's the preview before
the movie and I want to know what was
the inspiration for that because it's
cool and unusual and different but it's
also sort of representative of the tone
and different like the movie itself
you just answered your own question
um
no the the movie is odd and I think when
people hear that they're going to see a
biopic they have this idea of what a
biopic is and it's kind of cradled to
the Grave story and it's gonna feel good
and it's gonna have a wonderful Central
performance but it's going to tell you
it's going to be educational you know
and I always I've never been interested
in teaching like that I always feel like
when you're teaching you're losing it's
like I wanna I wanna make a movie you
know it's not class and um I wanted to
let you know right away that Flannery
O'Connor was really funny and really
peculiar and we were going to be really
peculiar as well and sort of kind of
knock you off balance to hopefully get
you into not knowing what to expect it's
kind of like a left hook yeah and the
thing and I'm sure both of you listen
I've seen way too many movies or
actually I've just seen a lot of movies
I was going to say as I said it I'm
realizing I totally effed that up but
one of the things I love is when a movie
does things right don't see what's
coming because you know normally in a
two-hour movie it it's like you know
every beat and any anyway one of the
things I enjoy do some math to it too
it's really interesting you know I mean
people haven't seen the movie now but it
was Maya and Laura are double cast
throughout the film and it was important
to start that's a strange thing did Maya
asked me early in the when we were
making the movie about what are some
movies I can watch to prepare where
where the actors have been double cast a
lot and there just aren't very many
other than comedic yeah yeah you know
you know Eddie Murphy does it
brilliantly all the time but there
aren't a lot of Dramas that that really
ask you to emotionally invest this way
with playing multiple roles in so that
was we knew that would be hard and I
also there's a lot of people in the
world that don't know at all who
Flannery O'Connor is and I thought that
little trailer tells them a little about
what kind of writer she is you know
she's not Louisa May Alcott she's not
Emily Dickinson you know we're still
conditioning is scandalous her writing
is scandalous she's wild and so I wanted
to let him know that
right off the bat on that note I could
ask you a thousand other questions but
uh you need to go and I need to do yet
another interview I'm sure you do I'm
just gonna say and I really mean this
sincerely congrats on the movie I
obviously hope everyone it's gonna be
for everyone to see thank you so much
for coming in our studio and thank you
thank you yeah